[Music]
sometimes it works sometimes it I can't
ever keep up
what I say let's go this dog rolls out
so I decided to take Maddy for a little
walk so we're out and I'm doing a little
Pokemon hunting it it's been a struggle
I've been going for at least thirty
minute walk every morning with Maddy and
I'll drop an egg I'll drop an incense
and I don't catch anything it's
extremely depressing I mean thirty
minutes and absolutely nothing what even
right now I'm sitting except Oki stop
and I've hardly got anything although I
did find Pikachu here once before so I'm
hoping for the best
we go back from Palm Springs yesterday
it was so incredibly hot there that we
could barely even go outside I'm
extremely excited to announce that Maddy
was able to swim on his own and yes I
read your comments and I know I
shouldn't be afraid to let my dog swim
because they are natural swimmers but
I'm an overprotective paranoid mom I
don't know what I can say it is our last
day here at Palm Springs actually we are
only here for another couple of hours
we decided that we're going to try one
more go at Maddy swimming because we
think that the problem yesterday is he's
a little bit nervous because the pool
that we put him in there wasn't much
room from actually swim
[Music]
I don't think he's gonna be a little
self appointee otta
this oh god that was trouble throw so
for those telling this isn't a point you
gotta you clearly just don't know
anything
thank you alright let's continue this
vlog camera he's doing all these weird
ISO settings what is what are you doing
just just work guy I found a levels only
gym level two Oh mommy's taking this
over all right so I basically got here
and just drop one of my Pokemon that was
it I ain't even fight guys it just
hatched a Snorlax oh my goodness I'm so
excited I can't believe I just hatch one
of these and I'm currently sitting at a
dual hoagie shop at church it's quite
exciting
he's a 1729 - this is great
oh my god I'm hatching something else
what is it what is it gonna be what is
it gonna be hmm holy moly
this is this is Greg Jenks huh oh what a
great day look at all these polka oh my
gosh I'm having a wonderful day
you see but I just caught a Charmander
327 not a big deal but we're getting
there
meda meda to break we walked really far
oh man I'm tired that was a little
walkie no one okay you still want to
play your monsters in here is it
monsters where's the monster give them
here I haven't done much updates to the
house still looking for furniture the
biggest update is the bedroom problem
that I had addressed previously this
carpet needs to go all the way up there
underneath the bed but the bed's really
heavy don't know what's gonna be
possible
Matty you hungry okay
did you steal my sweatpants please don't
rip those no you've ripped a hole in
every single pair of my pants every
single pair of my pants have a hole in
them stop wait you're gonna get hurt
stop drop open up shop Maddie's a rough
hunter hey listen to me
this has to stop leave it stop that
you're gonna fall down the steps now
you're gonna call random hurt yourself
you're literally pulling me stop honey
Neddy if you can figure out how to get a
laundry basket but I wouldn't put
anything past him so I was about to edit
my vlog for today a lot of you guys keep
asking if I'm doing Veda also some
people are asking me Jessie money to
post a video I opposed to pretty much
two videos the past week so there's a
ton of stuff to catch up on I also want
to ask you guys what you think I should
do with my gaming channel because I want
to play and I might play some call of
duty tonight we'll see how I do I played
in a few months actually which is really
really sad downloaded the last DLC this
morning also downloaded Lego Star Wars
on Xbox I'll probably play bad but I
don't think I would record it because I
just want to play it today I has missed
the week of cooking videos that I made
I'll put a link in the description where
you can check those all out and I'm
currently working on a week of Halloween
videos so I'm trying to figure out what
I should make I found a few really cute
things so if you guys have any
suggestions of some cool treats to make
for Halloween let me know I'll probably
start shooting those pretty soon so I
could have them ready for Halloween time
October I love Halloween it's like one
favorite holidays I'm gonna go play some
games maybe I'll post them maybe I won't
hi
I get so nervous when it's really quiet
because I think he's doing something bad
but he's just sitting he's tired from
our super long walk today I'll see you
guys later
die I don't know how to muddle I mean
I've seen them do it at bars before you
just kind of go up here